with the closing of a blockbuster store
in Australia this franchise in Bend
Oregon is the sole survivor of what was
once a multinational franchise no I'm
not is it really are you serious that's
awesome
sandy Harding is the general manager of
the store she started working here back
in 2004 at that time the chain had five
stores in band alone I grew up going to
the video store all the time and then
over the years video stores have always
been a part of my life and my husband
actually worked at a blockbuster store
when we were first married and that was
kind of an experience for us and then I
worked here and all of our kids have
worked here but yeah blockbuster has
been a part of my family for years
one of the main reasons this video still
still flourishes and even attracts
tourists from all over the country it's
nostalgia I've always been a fan of
blockbusters and renting it was like a
childhood thing for me and since I'm
driving across the country like of all
the stops that I wanted to do this is
the one that was on my radar the most
because I haven't been in a video store
in like over 16 years now but most LG
alone isn't what's keeping the store in
business it's the loyal customer base
that its staff have cultivated over the
years it is a product and part of the
community if this were ever does close
and I'm sure you know everything will
come to an end at some point I would be
very sad I think it will be the loss of
something really special and I think a
lot of people will mourn the loss of
Blockbuster as much as I will with
algorithms taking over the film industry
social meeting places like the one in
Bend are facing extinction
you